a glove full of bullet ants a kiss with
a cobra a casual chat with leo this
jackass spinoff was often more wild than
its johnny knoxville lead predecessor
but how much of wild boys was actually
real and how much was just pretend
stay tuned to find out
after watching an episode of wild boys
the origins of the name might sound
obvious chris pontius and steve oh are
in fact the wild boys as they perform
outrageous stunts with animals out in
the wild yet audience members might be
interested in the actual thought process
that went into the decision to name the
show wild boys which pontius opened up
about in a 2014 interview with journey
of a front man saying for wild boys we
were originally talking about names for
the show and the stupid names and
dimitri elioskovich was like i got one
he put on that duran duran song the wild
boys i thought we should use a z instead
of an s to make it even kookier and
everyone agreed i think that helped the
title clear anyway
though steve-o and chris pontius try to
be transparent with their fans when it
comes to realistic stunts and especially
where they're shooting there's one stunt
in particular that was a bit misleading
when asked about a stunt with a lion
being grabbed by the tail steve oh said
on his podcast steve o's wild ride
with jackass we were very very honest we
had integrity we never tried to deceive
the audience that was jackass but with
wild boys we took liberties to pretend
that we were in africa when actually we
were filming in california for the stunt
stevo and pontius were in a two-person
zebra suit steve oh admitted that it was
not in fact a wild lion that they
stumbled upon while on safari in africa
saying we quickly found out that a lion
in the wild on safari in africa you
don't get in a zebra suit and try to
play around with that thing audiences
might want their reality tv to be
authentic but in the case of wild boys
taking certain liberties shouldn't be
questioned the fact of the matter is the
wild boys still played with a lion this
wasn't the only time they fudged some of
the details when it came to a stunt with
an animal either on stevo's wild ride
stevo explained
every time that we filmed interacting
with a lion like every time we were
always pretending that we were in africa
but in fact we were in california at a
place called hollywood animals with that
said in his book professional idiot a
memoir steve o wrote that every time
wild animal expert manny pwigg was with
them they were in the united states
despite possibly claiming otherwise in
the episode in an attempt to make a more
entertaining show
this might come as a surprise for many
audiences but wild boys had a longer run
than the jackass tv series
the latter franchise of course made the
jump to the big screen to the tune of
four feature films but before that
jackass ran for three seasons and 25
episodes while wild boys won on a four
season run that lasted 32 episodes
despite the longer tenure wild boys is a
far more under the radar series while
jackass entered the mainstream and has
stayed there with every subsequent film
in fact wildboyz wasn't the only
successful jackass spin-off viva la bam
starring bam margera aired for 5 seasons
and 40 episodes wild boys also featured
other jackass stars from time to time
including jackass co-star johnny
knoxville and we man
though ultimate predator isn't
technically part of the jackass universe
it was created by manny puig who
appeared on jackass as well as some of
the wild boys excursions
that's the most stupidest thing i've
ever seen in my life the film features
pig interacting with wildlife most
notably sharks it also brings the wild
boys group back together as it features
steve oh and chris pontius so it's sort
of a wild boy spin-off just more
informational although pwigs still has
encounters with dangerous animals that
said ultimate predator is distinctly
different from wild boys as pwig
routinely educated the boys as opposed
to performing absurd stunts nevertheless
if you ever want to see pig interacting
with the wildlife outside of a show as
bizarre as wild boys and you also want
to see stevo and pontius join in on the
party then ultimate predator is an ideal
follow-up
it's not uncommon for a famous person to
rub shoulders with a fellow famous
person it is however uncommon for
someone to have a conversation with a
random stranger and realize later on
that you are speaking with leonardo
dicaprio but chris pontius isn't just
anyone and in addition to all of his
other wild stories he also pulled off
this feat when asked what his weirdest
encounter with a celebrity was during a
2022 interview with uproxx pontius
responded with an anecdote about an
interaction he had with someone at an
event saying i talked to this guy for
like an hour about animals and all the
crazy things we'd done and then the next
day my friend's like oh last night when
you were talking to leo and i was like
that was leonardo dicaprio i had no idea
it was him the key takeaway chris
pontius is not one to be starstruck and
leonardo dicaprio is a fan of wild boys
further proof that it's a show with
something for everyone
chris pontius and steve o seemed
fearless but wild boys fans might be
surprised to discover that pontius isn't
a fan of big cats like tigers and lions
in an interview with ign pontius
detailed his distaste for the formidable
felines when asked if there are any
animals he's irrationally afraid of
saying i don't like big cats really at
all cats are weird and they kind of snap
i don't really like them even if you
have a house cat or like the cat that
bit siegfried and roy they've worked
with these animals like their entire
life and then all of a sudden they just
killed him
who could blame him despite pontius
testing his luck with wild animals over
the years it would appear he is able to
push past his biggest fears he doesn't
fancy big cats yet he's not afraid to
get in the ring with them
i hear the growling come over here so
we are getting dangerously close to the
florida panthers
dangerously close
chris pontius has performed a myriad of
outlandish stunts over the years yet his
favorite stunt of all time is easy for
him to pick and it involved a snake
opening up in a 2014 journey of a front
man interview ponte has said
i think my favorite thing i ever did
period was on wild boys the biggest
overcoming your own fierce thing that i
ever did was kissing a king cobra on the
head typically people don't say their
favorite thing they've ever done was
kissing a snake let alone something as
deadly as the king cobra but pontius
isn't your average stunt performer he
went on to admit that the opportunity
came about when director jeff tremaine
told him the night before that they had
found some guys who had access to a
non-de-venomized king cobra while they
were in indonesia pontius called this
stunt the kiss of death and suffice it
to say it energized him saying i touched
him a few times and i started wanting to
give it a kiss so i just went for it i
felt like a million bucks i felt just
happy to be alive really it's just one
more example of the many ways wild boys
had no issue pushing the limits whether
a scene was scripted or not we're just
happy that pontius survived his favorite
stunt
chris pontius was made for the camera
he's comically gifted a natural
storyteller and he's not afraid of
anything those are excellent qualities
to have especially for any jackass cast
member i'm ultra megadeux chris parties
and this is my home
pontius to say the least has performed
some wild stunts over the years yet his
most painful stunt was called the glove
of ants and it went down on wild boys
in a 2022 interview with up rocks
pontius recalled the experience saying
it's a rite of passage for this tribe in
the amazon you put these ants called
bullet ants they weave them into this
glove and when boys come of age you put
this glove on that has hundreds of ants
that have the most painful sting of any
insect
he explained that the passage is
accompanied by a shaman singing an
8-minute song during which the ants are
stinging the recipient hundreds of times
chris summed it up by saying
that was by far the most painful
dreadful thing i've ever done in my life
combined
it's just like venom for 24 hours and
there's nothing you can do about it so
yeah that was the worst thing i would
never do that again
reminder pontius has been in the ring
with bengal tigers lions snapping
turtles and so on and so forth yet his
most painful experience involved dealing
with ants that's saying something
in his book professional idiot a memoir
steve o wrote about the decision to end
wild boys he recalled that the series
probably could have gone more than four
seasons yet the show had become too much
like jackass going along with that
sentiment stevo told the hollywood
reporter that wild boys in a way spawned
jackass number two johnny knoxville had
previously declared that jackass was
over after the first movie but when he
joined the wild boys while they were
filming in russia he seemed to have
redeveloped the daredevil itch according
to with steve oh we were on this trip in
russia at this counter-terrorism
training camp knoxville says have the
dog bite me and shoot me with the nine
millimeter gun while the dog's biting me
and tremaine says to knoxville hey whoa
let's not do this for mtv2
if you have that in you let's make
another movie and knoxville had it in
him and that was number two ultimately
the jackass movies would go on to
partially adopt the wild boy style
including foreign locations and lots of
animal stunts
legendary skateboarder tony hawk has
endured some brutal injuries over the
years it goes with the territory of
being a professional daredevil yet his
worst injury ever actually came during
an appearance on wild boys appearing on
stevo's wild ride hawk recalled the time
he tested fate and attempted to complete
a loop on his skateboard for wild boys
hawk needless to say didn't make it and
crashed hard the damage he broke his
pelvis and thumb and he also cracked his
skull
that one was pretty ugly and
definitely life-threading i hit my head
really hard
unfortunately for hawk this wasn't even
supposed to be his stunt stevo was
supposed to perform it but had
previously shattered his ankle while
jumping off a porta-potty hawk talked
about the injury during an interview
with the guardian saying that was a
bummer breaking your pelvis is
debilitating you can't walk you can't
cough you just have to sit and wait for
it to heal
all good things must come to an end and
wild boys was no exception with the show
concluding after four seasons however
there's still a chance the show could
return although that should be taken
with a grain of salt during an ask me
anything on reddit to promote jackass
forever chris pontius and johnny
knoxville were inevitably asked about
doing a reboot of wild boys and pontius
replied
i would love to do a wild boys reboot i
don't think it would be called wild boys
but i would love to do another nature
slash adventure show and i want
knoxville to be on it with me
there's a chance that pontius was trying
to avoid dashing fans hopes for a
revival especially since he and
knoxville were promoting their new movie
but if his words are any indication
audience members can still hold out hope
for a wild boy's return even if it comes
with a different title
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mtv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you